my name is Alessandro manana porque and
I'm the chief economist the great
challenges Nicole tengo que si se basic
wait the question is when should the amf
and they were back before but now i will
type ones so they were back at AMS as
you all know where he will make him
fortify us a second world war two
structure of the new global war and of
course because of their birth they were
born in bretton woods living in America
woods a mess to let say regulate shorter
issues in monitoring forest the world
men work for developmental loan to
strategic issues and the what is now the
poor Trade Organization for a regulation
work given their birth in 1845 they
basically reflect they were order of 95
so the the countries that had one second
to work at the greater say in the war of
this institution and to the US the UK
now Japan so eventually we became
institution that have emerging market
under represented to China Brazil Russia
Mexico are not represent as much as they
should if we had their contribution to
global growth now the world has changed
they've doesn't need crisis has already
accelerated dis change and the emerging
markets are contributing more and more
lower growth so they need to be
represented more again in a few numbers
in 1995 a share of new markets in global
trade growth filter percent and doesn't
intend it goes to food fighters foreign
exchange reserves we're in a d90 held
two third of foreign hostages were held
by
by developed markets and only one-third
by merging markets now the tree show us
flipped in 2010 emerging markets code to
third of your shirt and developed
markets only one of the FBI is going to
go to markets one will come from
emerging markets themselves sovereign
wealth fund are playing increasing role
in financing development and financing
financing global growth so all this
basically says that emerging markets
need to have a greater say in the
institution that are regulating the
global economic develop the IMF
definitely need to have the higher role
liquor going forward we will witness the
declining live of the dollar reserves of
currency as the sole reserve currency we
over the next decade we will see more
assured courtesies that will accompany
with all the war bank needs movers see
the development of the world noble
poverty needs to be different many
people don't have access to educational
access friend from paralysis water and
they need to be helped getting there so
I just see lotta finish school but an
increased role for information financial
institutions but with the essential
habit that reforms in terms of giving it
greater force energy markets are very
much needed in logistical surface thank
you very much